hello and welcome back to game review my
name is Caleb Denby and today I wanted
to take a look at one of my own games
that I'm kind of proud of at a
tournament I recently played at the US
Amateur Team East or also known as the
the world amateur team tournament all
the way out in Parsippany New Jersey
made quite a trip here all the way from
st. Louis and I got to play some strong
players for it this is a game I actually
had against Andrew tang and why don't we
take a look at it the game started with
d4 Knight f6 and Bishop f4 entering the
London system I play a line with a six
now III b6 Knight f3 very simple natural
developing moves by white white of
course putting all the pieces on the
London squares and then continuing
continuing with the game I continued
with Bishop e7 not really the main stuff
but the London isn't really the type of
pressing opening where you have to be
very very meticulous about your move
orders and play deep theoretical
knowledge you can kind of put your
pieces where you want to put them
because white isn't making huge claims
in the center with just this D pawn
white continued with Knight bTW - and I
challenge the center a little bit with
c5 and now after c3 I went ahead and
castled black or white plays this move
h3 giving this Bishop a little bit of a
flight square in the event that night h5
ever comes on the board and now I had a
decision to make here I could play d6 I
could play d5 or I could start
developing my queen side pieces but in
the game there was actually a very
distinct reason I had left these two
pieces undeveloped and for that reason I
chose my next move d6
Smoove is aimed at controlling this EA v
square preventing this Knight from
jumping into it and also allowing white
the opportunity to develop his Bishop
which is exactly what I wanted
now due to the fact that these two
pieces have remained undeveloped I have
this extra option here to not develop
this Bishop to b7 but instead to come
all the way out to a stick
and trade-off White's most important
minor piece in the London that being
this very powerful LightSquared Bishop
so now that I'm getting rid of this
Bishop of course the move like Bishop c2
wouldn't really be advisable you can't
really castle with this Bishop on a6 and
black would actually have a little bit
of an advantage here so white does in
fact take off these bishops now white
simply castles and here the downside to
my play yes I got rid of White's most
important minor piece but my night is a
bit sidelined so I simply take this time
to bring this knight back to b8 where it
started and so on the next move I can
come up to c6 which is a much better
square for this Knight controlling the
center controlling the a file in the
meantime why displayed a for a very nice
smooth restricting my plan of expanding
on the Queen side but I just continued
white continues with Knight C for making
threats on d6 so I took on d4 making
sure the Queen couldn't join in on that
fun
he takes d4 I simply keep improving my
pieces with rook c8 rook e1
now I continue with d5 I could in theory
try to continue with my plan on the
Queen side but the fact of the matter is
it's just a little bit too slow in this
case can imagine moves like 93 coming on
the board and now if I want to keep
playing on the Queen side if I really
force the issue I'm gonna run into moves
like d5 coming from white and this is
something you have to be a little bit
care careful of you have to always be
calculating making sure that your plans
aren't too slow for the position so
because of that in this case I realized
e5 was really a main threat from white
that was something he was he was hoping
to achieve
so I played e5 myself taking away that
option this night now jumps into e5 I'm
more than happy to take off these
Knights in play 90 for myself
this is another idea behind d5
controlling this efore square allows me
to improve this piece this Queen jumps
out to e2 perhaps I'm to make some
threats on this e six square and at this
time I realized that this Bishop is
actually a lot more useful than my
bishop here on e7 you might have been
told that
in theory the good bishop is the bishop
on the other color the opposite color to
your pawn structure and the bad bishop
is the bishop locked on the same color
as your main pawn structure or pawn
chain but in this case it turns out the
whites bishop is more useful than blacks
in my opinion White's bishop on this
very natural diagonal is controlling
some key important squares meanwhile
this Bishop it's controlling a lot of
squares but they aren't the most
relevant ones you know I'd very much
would like to put my pieces on squares
like c7 and b8 but I simply can't with
this Bishop here because of that the
best moves are aimed at actually
contesting this bishop so move like
Bishop d6 would be good instead I chose
Bishop Age for highlighting that this
pawn is a bit weak and rubato stripped
back to f1 to defend it and then I play
Bishop g5 offering a trade of these
bishops white accepts and now continues
with a5 trying to put some pressure on
my Queen side structure here I continued
with Queen d2 the idea being you can't
really take this Queen do you to some
tactics here Knight B 3 will come with a
fork so instead of takes we see Queen B
5 and now I simply capture on a5 with
the idea of using this B file to attack
this beep on Andrew played the nice move
Knight f3 trying to force this Queen out
of d2 and in the game I did not think it
would be advisable to come to c2 because
it looks as the rook c1 traps my queen
but actually here there's a very funny
one funny move to save the queen
I'll let you try to find it of course it
is a six drawing this Queen away from
some important squares I was never gonna
find this in the game though so I simply
retreated my Queen back to f4 a very
natural move Andrew takes on a5 a very
natural play by me I just play the rook
to b8 nothing too fancy nothing too
complicated just put the pieces on good
squares the Queen comes back to e2 now I
want to attack this pawn and I want to
defend this pawn so rook b7 from me this
trick comes over to a 1 simply play rook
b8 with the point being that if white
wants to capture this a pawn
I'll go ahead and capture this beep on
with temple on the Queen with threats to
f2 so of course Andrew doesn't take on a
seven instead simply bringing this Rick
back to defend this beep on and from
here I play the move h6 creating left
from my King getting out of any back
rank made threats
Andrew continued with g3 forcing this
Queen back and now he tries to reroute
this night and this position is actually
pretty balanced Andrew does have a plan
to improve it though and it all involves
using this night effectively so for the
moment these two pawns kind of hang in
this balance where if either side wants
to capture the other one they're going
to lose the the pawn left behind and
there wouldn't be much for white if he
loses this beep on in fact black would
be significantly better due to this
weakness on c3 if this b-pawn were to
fall so who could have fixed this
problem Andrew wants to bring his knight
back to d3 freeing up his rooks to take
this a pawn
however black can't can't meet this
pretty adequately here I chose a five
and after ninety three I'm simply gonna
play rook b5 defending this pawn from
this threat that the rifts have have
made to it
white improves his king with king g2 and
now I decide it's time to improve my own
night as well I would put more pressure
on b2 so I do so with 96
the idea being I want to come in to c4
white now plays Knight c5 making a
threats of course Knight a six can't
allow that
so simply Queen c6 defense note that
since this Knight has vacated the d3
square once again I don't really have to
defend this pawn thanks to this move
rook takes b2 so instead of that Andrew
actually previous this rook over to e1
which was a pretty strange move to my
eyes so I'm not sure what he wanted to
achieve with this rook on a1 I simply
continued with my plan Knight c4
additionally if this move has the nice
side effect of controlling the e6 square
which my may have been on Andrews mind
with the move rook e1
some nasty sacrifices here but no need
to worry so night see four attacks this
beep on as I wanted and now perhaps the
best move for white is simply Knight b3
bringing this this Knight back to defend
the pawn once again and trying to keep
this balance instead white plays this
move b3 and now I'll let you at home try
to find the move that really actually
gives black a substantial advantage here
it should be a kind of natural to you to
want to play this move because it really
just kind of destroys the entire white
white structure alright hopefully you
found it of course it is not 96 not rook
takes B 3 but rook takes c5 the exchange
sacrifice here is actually quite good
for black it's what I played in the game
as well of course you can't take the
knight the ripple recapture so white
must take the rook but now after rook
takes b3 black only has one pawn for the
exchange at the moment but c5 will fall
soon after and there's going to be some
nasty pressure on the c3 pawn as well in
the meantime the knight is locked on a
very nice outpost on c4 controlling this
a5 pawn as well making sure there's no
threats to it and so because of this
black actually has a pretty nice edge
here white continued with Queen c2
attacking the rook defending the pawn I
play the move rook b5 it's actually
better here is rook b8 the idea being
you can avoid the rook trade from b8
whereas after it b5 and rook to b1 you
cannot avoid the rook trade due to rook
b8 with some back rank issues for black
so after it b5 rip b1 I play the move d4
check and after King g1 i sat there and
I calculated and I calculated and I
calculated some more and I couldn't
figure it out it was just too
complicated for me it turns out to move
95 does actually grant black a little
bit of an edge after rook takes b5 the
most natural move we play Knight f3
check of course the King can't come to
these two squares because 91 check would
pick up the Queen or actually and it
also kind of checkmate
so instead we see after night of three
check white would play King f1 queen
takes b5 and now the move c4 is actually
the best white can do when in fact after
Queen takes c5 black has a nice little
hold on the position with this Queen
very naturally defending the pawns and
this night going to come back to e5 and
put some pressure on c4 the line that I
didn't like was after Queen e2 check
I really couldn't figure out this
position in my head with 91 and D takes
c3 in my head I was kind of just
terrified of this C pawn and I didn't
want to really go in for this
so I calculated I calculated I
calculated and I couldn't figure it out
so in the game I gave up and took on c3
but unfortunately for me this allows
white some very nice very nice moves
here he takes on b5 immediately you
cannot capture this pawn due to Queen B
1 check with a nasty fork so Andrew
simply brings the strip back to a 1 also
eyeing rook c1 to keep control of these
pawns I capture on c5 but now after
Queen c3 white is going to have a
distinct advantage here my extra pawns
are on e6 and a5 neither of them are
really going to be useful and so the
extra exchange is worth quite a bit more
here I play at Queen d5 trying to unpin
and you played Queen b3 trying to pin I
played Queen e4 trying to unpin and
replayed rook a for trying to pin I
played Queen e1 trying to unpin white
played King g2 and then I celebrated
because I unpinned and then I
immediately pinned myself again with
Queenie 4 check and now after King aged
- I'm actually not able to save this
night from capture here there's no way
to break free from this pin besides to
play Queen e2 and this gives Andrew a
very interesting opportunity here to go
in for a a pretty unique endgame an
endgame that I hadn't seen before maybe
maybe Andrew had seen it before I'm sure
he's played more chess than me but that
on game would be after Queen takes c4 of
course you can't take this with the rook
because this is a simple draw but Queen
takes d4 is is a try Queen takes F to
check if you want to avoid the putt
perpetual you can't go back to H 2 so
you play king g1 and
we would end up and quite an interesting
endgame where eventually white is going
to have to avoid the Czechs by offering
up a trade of Queens let's say with
Queen d3 here take stakes and after move
like g5 and Newark takes a5 going to
have four pawns for black in exchange
for a rook and this isn't really an
endgame I had ever had the pleasure of
playing before but it turns out it
should be a draw should be a draw who
knows what would have happened if we
ever got here in the game but Andrew
didn't like the look of it perhaps he
thought it was risking a bit too much
for pawns can be scary so instead after
Queen e2 he simply plays Queen B a check
and reroutes in this Queen to f4 I
continue with Knight d2 creating some
threats to the King of course you can't
take f7 because this would simply be a
pretty easy draw here with the knight on
f3
so Andrew first stops the threat to f3
and now this pawn is actually under
danger or in danger so I play f6 white
plays G for giving us King a bit more
space I worry about this Knight over to
e5 and this gives white the opportunity
to go in for this endgame and the sudden
game is actually not so simple for it
for black to try to draw at first glance
the engine gives this move g5 as being
blacks best move to draw the game but
after f4 takes takes and king g6 there
are still two pawns left on the board
and unless black is able to really get
rid of both of them comfortably and not
allow white to make a passed pawn like
is gonna be in serious danger of losing
this game so instead of g5 you know I
didn't really like the look of that I
played a different move and that is H 5
H 5 here with the idea being that after
G takes h5 hopefully I can regain this
pawn with King age 6 and King age 5
however I noted here that perhaps there
is some danger due to this move f4
perhaps coming on the board with some
threats to this epon and didn't really
like the look of this
for for black here so instead of going
with my original plan trying to
recapture I instead rerouted this night
over to g5 and played e5 the idea with
the idea of permanently controlling this
f4 square keeping white fruit from ever
playing f4 in the game white plays King
g4 so he gets to keep this pawn now in
exchange for my maneuvers
I play ninety six rook takes a
five-night f4 and now Rick a eight and
thankfully for me this turns out to be a
fortress there's there's simply no way
to really make progress for white and
I'll try and explain why now really the
only way to make progress in this type
of position is to get this king
somewhere where can kind of influence
the the base of black spawn Shane but
the problem for white is let's say I
pass the problem for white is if you
play King an f5 in this position like
it's gonna be able to take this aged
pawn and once this age pawn disappears
these two pawns aren't very threatening
actually if as you tried in the game you
play King f5 after the night steps to e6
White has this very nice move Knight d4
check which guards these two squares and
the king is nothing better than to
return to g4 this is what actually
happened in the game I returned to e6
now this rook steps to e8 I come back to
h4 and once again we have this situation
where if the king wants to advance I'll
drop the H pawn so white wastes another
tempo and now he is guarding the e6
square but there's also this e to square
for the knight just shuffle between and
so now I still have access to d4 so
after King f5 94 check steps on the
board again and Andrew shows King efore
in this case and so I simply prepare to
bring this kink this Knight back to F
for not allowing like to break through
and so Andrew finally gave up on
breaking this fortress in this manner
and played h6
this is an idea used by white to get my
king out of its little shelter here on
h7 I play
takes of course would be a pretty big
mistake to play pawn takes it allows the
White King in and black would be very
much losing so King takes instead okay
che check King Aegeus or King g6 h5 King
f7 and now my King has been forced from
this square on h7
but unfortunately for white it's it's
still not enough to try to win the game
rook a8 was White's choice I bring this
Knight back to f4 hitting this pawn and
now after a couple checks white
continues with age six all once again
trying to break up the structure in this
case I'm forced to accept this and take
back with my H pawn but thankfully the
white king still can't quite get and
thanks to this move Knight d5 and after
the check 97 and now after King e6 this
is very very clearly just going to be a
draw black has no issues with keeping
this one pawn from ever becoming a queen
and these two pawns are going to defend
against any threats that can make the
game continued with King age 595 King f5
King g7 night of four rook a six simply
Knight h5 check King f7 King g5 rook a3
I played efore advancing the pawns just
a bit and now Andrew played f3
essentially giving up on winning the
game and after a couple more moves
he took my final pawn I captured his
rook in the game was drawn due to
insufficient material so this is my game
against Andrew tang I was pretty happy
with the way that I played managed to
just play simple natural chess that's
all you really have to do against even
super-strong players like Andrew tang
just play moves that makes sense
play moves that activate your pieces and
if you don't make any serious mistakes
then you can't really lose the game
thank you so much for joining me on this
episode of game review my name is Caleb
done B and I will see you next time